-Welcome, everyone,
welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I want to wish everyone a happy
St. Patrick's Day to you there.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Yeah, St. Patrick's
is a major holiday.
In fact, all the banks
were closed today,
although that had nothing to do
with St. Patrick's Day.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, everyone's talking
about this --
following the recent
bank crashes,
President Biden
has asked Congress
for more authority
to punish bank executives.
[ Oohs ]
-Then Bernie Sanders
picked up some brass knuckles
and said --
[ As Sanders ]
Or I can just handle it myself.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Biden's had it.
It's like a movie detective
who puts his badge in the drawer
and goes,
"I'm not a cop tonight."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, Biden isn't
messing around.
Apparently, he wants
to punish the bank CEOs
by chaining all their pens
to the desk.
[ Laughter ]
Some more big news -- I read
that law enforcement agencies
are preparing
for the possibility that,
as early as next week,
former President Trump
could be indicted.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Which is why Trump
is currently packing
for spring break in Switzerland.
[ Laughter ]
I think even Trump
knows it's coming
because today he was walking
around in a green shirt
that said,
"Kiss me, I'm indicted."
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-At this point, Trump has
so many legal problems,
everyone's filling out brackets
for which one finally gets him.
[ Laughter ]
They're like Stormy Daniels
versus Georgia election
tampering.
I don't know.
Did you guys see this?
According to a new poll,
49% of Americans
would support banning TikTok.
[ Boos and nos ]
Yeah, that's pretty much half.
And, apparently,
even people on TikTok are split
on whether to ban the app.
-Really?!
[ Laughter ]
-I think it's pretty clear why.
For example, this user
doesn't want to ban TikTok.
-3, 2, 1.
[ Explosions ]
[ Cheering ]
Yeah, while this user does.
[ Hip hop plays ]
[ Ohhs, laughter, and applause ]
Here's another example.
This user doesn't want
to ban TikTok.
-[Indistinct]
[ Awws ]
Yeah.
But this user does.
-YOLO.
[ Laughter ]
-[Indistinct]
-Aah!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You took the whole house!
[ Cheering ]
-Wow! The whole thing.
He's still in the slide.
-He's still in the slide.
-Yeah, yeah,
he's living in there, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, this user
doesn't want to ban TikTok.
-1, 2, 3.
-[ Inhaling sharply ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, while this user does.
-Cheers.
-[ Inhales sharply ]
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
-Oh!
[ Rimshot ]
[Indistinct]
Well, guys, March Madness is
in full swing
and one of the big upsets,
so far, was 15 seed Princeton
knocking off number 2 Arizona.
[ Ohhs, cheering, and applause ]
Everyone in Princeton
was acting pretty cocky
and that was even
before the game started.
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Some business news --
I saw that IKEA
has recalled thousands
of mirrors
because they could fall
and cut people.
-[ Snickers ]
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, customers should've
seen this coming
because the name
of the mirror is
"Fall and cut you."
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you go.
That's "Valunkutu."
[ Laughter ]
You guys, get this --
7-Eleven just announced
that they are launching
a huge new
electric vehicle
charging network.
It's perfect if you've ever been
at 7-Eleven and thought,
"I want to stay here
for 60 minutes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I want to stay here
for more than ten minutes."
[ Laughter ]
It sounds high-tech,
but all they do is
plug your Tesla
into the hot dog roller.
-Really?
-Yeah, that's right.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right, you fill your car
up at 7-Eleven,
then, an hour later,
the car gets heartburn.
[ Laughter ]
It's interesting.
Guys, listen to this --
according to new research,
horseback riding could actually
help ease back pain.
[ Murmuring ]
Unless, of course,
you're the horse.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Finally, you guys,
I'm very excited.
It is St. Patrick's Day today.
I mean, this is a big deal.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I love it.
But I got to say, every year,
people focus too much
on the stereotypes
and not enough on what makes,
really, St. Patrick's Day
and Ireland so special
and, to show you what I mean,
I actually wrote a little song.
Roots, can I get a note?
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Irish accent ]
♪ Oh oh ♪
♪ The 17th of March is here ♪
♪ The day has got me thinkin' ♪
♪ St. Patty's Day and Ireland ♪
♪ So much more than drinkin' ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ The cliffs of Moher
are gorgeous ♪
♪ If great heights
you do not fear ♪
♪ A lovely place
to see the view ♪
♪ And crack an ice cold...
water ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪ Go and see the Blarney Stone ♪
♪ And kiss it,
if you're frisky ♪
♪ Then wash your mouth out
with a giant shot ♪
♪ Of Irish...LaCroix ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ There are no snakes
on Emerald Isle ♪
♪ No creepy crawly scalies ♪
♪ So, just relax,
enjoy some coffee ♪
♪ Mixed with creamy oat milk ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Pick a four-leaf clover
hidden underneath a shrub ♪
♪ Then show it off
to all your mates ♪
♪ Down at the local library ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ To Dublin or to Galway,
if you want to see a sight ♪
♪ And watch two old men argue
till it turns into a... ♪
Cordial acceptance
of their differences.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
♪ Now, my tune is over ♪
♪ Time to climb into me bunk ♪
♪ That's all to say
this St. Patrick's Day ♪
♪ Screw it, let's get drunk ♪